[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre en septembre 2020 vous
déclariez notre pays n'est pas un
coupe-gorge et là sans l'espace de deux
mois plusieurs meurtres à larme blanche
vous donne tort en mai un médecin
militaire est tué à Marseille le 10
juillet un retraité poignardé à Trappes
le lendemain une femme est assassinée à
Montpellier le 14 juillet deux jeunes
sont mortellement blessés à Metz et
Amiens tout récemment évidemment nous
avons tous été extrêmement choqué par le
triple meurtre à l'arme blanche à Angers
ou trois jeunes hommes âgés de 16 à 20
ans issus de la communauté wallisienne
ont perdu la vie tout simplement parce
qu'il portait secours à une jeune femme
agressée sexuellement
malheureusement ces faits se multiplient
et pas seulement dans nos métropoles
sans réelle stratégie dans le déni et
l'émotion je dirais de routine votre
gouvernement participe à la banalisation
de cette triste réalité en refusant de
nommer ses actes barbares tel qu'ils
sont et par exemple en les qualifiant de
faits divers ou par le président Macron
de simple incivilité
seul ministre il n'est pas question ni
de stigmatiser ni de prétendre détenir
une quelconque baguette magique mais
simplement de vous interroger sur la
réponse que vous apportez aux familles
qui ne se résignent pas qui n'acceptent
pas que la vie de quiconque peut ainsi
être aussi facilement fauché dans la rue
[Applaudissements]